there is a certain natural phenomenon
that you may or may not be familiar with
a facial expression made by the human
when one of its number is holding and
reading a book the head is slightly
raised turned at twenty to thirty
degrees from the forward eyes widen
slowly pupils dilate vision enhances
this followed by a momentary paralysis
in which a number of subjects have
recorded a feeling of quote loveliness
here it is in its closest approximation
and here are some of the commonly cited
causes what is that feeling when you're
driving away from people and they recede
on the plane till you see their specks
dispersing it's the two huge world
vaulting us and it's goodbye but we lean
forward to the next crazy venture
beneath the skies for a moment a phrase
tried to take shape in my mouth and my
lips parted like a dumb man's as though
there was more struggling upon them than
a wisp of startled air but they made no
sound and what I had almost remembered
was in communicable forever a solemn
consideration when I enter a great city
by night that every one of those darkly
clustered houses encloses its own secret
that every room and every one of them
encloses its own secret that every
beating heart and the hundreds of
thousands of breaths there is in some of
its imaginings a secret to the heart
nearest it there are more things in
heaven and earth Horatio than are dreamt
of in your philosophy
maybe you know the feeling and if you do
you could like I did produce a list of
quotes that triggers the same natural
phenomenon in you and knowing that you
know that these words don't just knock
us around intellectually but physically
they twist us into knots or untie the
tightest ones within us they put us
face-to-face with our illusions our
bigotries our preconceptions you know
that to grasp just one sentence of the
very best writing is to grasp a thousand
sentences of great writing which is to
grasp
ten thousand sentences of good right and
in this way great books are very
expensive things they come at the cost
of thousands and thousands of sentences
they come at the cost of dozens of
easier books and children's books and
picture books and simple poems and sing
along songs they come at the cost of a
room to read room to read promotes
literacy around the world by building
libraries and getting kids access to
books helping millions to put their very
first down payments on Dickens or
Shakespeare this is a phenomenon we
should help everyone to feel